fires engulfing large swaths of the
Amazon rainforest the smoke is traveling
far and wide it darkened the skies over
Sal Paulo which is more than 2,000
kilometers south of the burn area the
scope of the fires is massive these
satellite images from NASA show how the
smoke has covered most of the northern
half of Brazil which is larger than the
whole of Europe the Amazon produces 20%
of the world's oxygen and is home to
more than 3 million species of plants
and animals fires in the Amazon are a
natural occurrence often started by
lightning strikes but that doesn't
explain the sudden increase in fires
this year which environmentalists say
has been exacerbated by cattle ranchers
and soy farmers clearing forests at an
increased pace enforcement of Amazon
burning has been scaled back under
President jarba senado a longtime
skeptic of environmental concerns
Paulson arrows slashed government
funding to environmental agencies and on
Tuesday suggested the fires were being
staged by NGOs to embarrass his
government I am under the impression
that it could have been set by the NGOs
because they had asked for money
what was their intention to bring about
problems for Brazil when fires burn in
the Amazon the area is so large
there's nothing firefighters can do to
put them out when these fires finally do
go away environmentalists say that
damage will have been done here it is
really much of it is permanently wasted
in a sense that it takes ages to regrow
forests and it can never be regrown in
the original way the Amazon rainforest
often called the lungs of planet Earth
now filled with smoke and fire and
choking one of the world's most diverse
ecosystems Gabe Rolando al-jazeera